very narrow okay so i'm still
as far as i can see i'm still one game
up
and there are two games to go
so this means that i mean in a pretty
decent position
so okay this stuff has been working
reasonably well i think
okay so we just go c5 this time
we'll play a symmetrical english then
let's see what he uh with he has in mind
played this against kasim in
isle of man peter grant swiss
he he went for knight of six there h6 is
a good move
another circus
what's the winner like did you go d4 e3
or
maybe this is what i had against wesley
before in
in cote d'ivoire
but maybe this is actually it
it's a shame that i can't remember i
can't remember anything
i don't know if this is truth or real
okay castle seems reasonable which
knight c3
shouldn't be an option
now is this where i go bishop d2
i have a feeling that i may have had
this again firstly before
a bit stupid that i can't remember so
the idea of
this is that when if he takes a bunch of
times on
d4 then h6 is hanging
there's one more point
and
i'm winning this thing
yeah this feels eerily familiar
something like bishop f4 knight of 5
92 or something that's what i did
maybe
okay whatever
i feel like there's a hard hard limit to
how bad this can be
i do have the salani but h5s
386 is always hanging and at least i'm a
little bit better developed
those bishops are pointing at least half
menacingly
i guess this is uh queenside
uh yeah i think i'm just trying to
scream
and i feel as long as he he doesn't
develop
[ __ ] on c8 then
i'm never ever in any trouble
okay take on b7
don't know why i did this
seems unnecessary
i'll take rook d1
and am i not just a pawn up
i ask thee
bishop b5 there's knight c3
so no worries there
and otherwise i think he's hard-pressed
to find reasonable compensation
yeah now i'm dropping back
no shame in this particular retreat as
far as i can see
okay yeah just for d2 i believe
i do have b3 bishop b5
knight c3 knight d4 there's
i think many nasty options frame
bishop d6
yeah it looks very good actually
oh it's not going to speed up
considerably
e3 is an ugly move though let's see
three which basically this is
maybe not ideal but i believe i'm still
quite a bit better
it doesn't take i'll take and go d5
no sorry if it doesn't go f6 and if i go
f if he goes f6 i'll go bishop f4
fg file taking vision to t1
okay he goes f6
okay d5 i suppose
c1 again
so i should just should just play at
some point
but i have a pretty nice pawn out
but a lot can still happen
okay we'll go king h2
i think and then light a4 is the idea
not allowing a fork i need to
now there must be some ideas right
d6 it
getting so short on time
but i am much better here will be
five
so short on time so let's try on time
maybe you can take rook d2
i shouldn't have allowed this
i know he's got king of seven damn it
dummy damn it
it's not good simply no good
time management is the stuff of absolute
nightmares
and i don't even have okay i work c5
that's a good find at the very least
because you cannot take on f2 because
they're still going to be
they're still going to be issues
okay i'm at least somewhat backing base
i'm winning upon
take g4
he's getting desperate now
oh what'd i do king of three
check go g5 remove
take it knight d4 remove
yes okay
check for g7
he lost some time and i win
what a what a battle
like that that was that was a real
battle i was two nil up
and i just barely pull it off so many
games where i just think
think think and it just keeps on coming
up with uh with good moves
to to um to make it difficult for me
so well done wesley um
great fight and uh yeah what can i say i
happen to have made it
if even if it was just barely